Cosmo and BuzzFeed have decided they
have their new crusade their new crusade
is chip and Joanna Gaines they may know
these P I don't watch chip and Joanna
Gaines you guys watch shipment
fixer-upper okay so my wife I'm sure
watches this show right this is the
people who find houses and they fix them
up and as the show is really really
popular and they're very very upset over
at Cosmo because chip and Joanna Gaines
his pastor preaches that homosexuality
is a sin and then the subtitle but do
they agree and the the entire article is
just about how terrible it is that they
go to a church where the pastor thinks
homosexuality is a sin BuzzFeed had this
mind-blowing scoop a mind-blowing scoop
their church Antioch community Community
Church is a non-denominational
evangelical mission based mega church
and their pastor Jimmy Siebert who
described the gains as his dear friends
takes a hard line against same-sex
marriage and promotes converting LGBT
people into being straight when reached
by phone Antioch community churches
communications director pointed me
toward the church's website under
beliefs where it states marriage is the
uniting of one man and one woman in
covenant commitment for a lifetime so
the media are going nuts oh my god these
Christians go to a church where they
actually read the Bible that's crazy
that's totally nuts now for people who
are unfamiliar with this little book
called the Bible a little book called
the Bible it's not actually that warm
toward homosexuality like the pastor is
doing something called reading and in
the Bible it says that not homosexuality
is at home homosexual activity is a sin
to be more to be more precise because
the Bible itself doesn't say anything
about desire it says stuff about
behavior right so Leviticus twice
condemns homosexual behavior it says you
shall not lie with a male as with woman
is an abomination Leviticus 18:22 it
does something very similar in Leviticus
20:13 it actually prescribes the death
penalty right in the New Testament it
says in Romans because of this God gave
them over to shameful lusts even their
women exchanged natural sexual relations
for unnatural one in the same way the
men also abandoned natural relations
with women and were inflamed with lust
from one another men committed shameful
acts with other men and receives in
themselves the due penalty for their
error in Corinthians same deal or do you
not know that the unrighteous will not
inherit the kingdom of God do not be
deceived neither the sexually immoral
nor idolaters nor adulterers nor men who
practice homosexuality nor thieves nor
the greedy nor drunkards nor nor
revilers nor swindlers will inherit the
kingdom of God Timothy says the same
thing the wise for people who are
sexually immoral or who practice
homosexuality or our slave traders Liars
promise breakers etc etc by the way
that's not even touching the traditional
biblical interpretations of the events
in Sodom and Gomorrah so the headline on
all this really should be oh my god
somebody goes to a church where the
pastor's read the Bible that should be
the actual headline here now the reason
that this is so stupid the reason this
is so stupid is there's no evidence
whatsoever that the gaines family has
ever discriminated against a gay person
there's no evidence whatsoever that they
mistreat gay people there's no evidence
whatsoever that they are even interested
in doing any of those things but for the
left the thought crime has been
committed if you believe in the Bible
that in and of itself is a thought crime
this is why same-sex marriage is used as
a club to beat up churches the same
people who think you shouldn't be able
to go to a church where people believe
that homosexual activity is a sin those
people believe the state should come in
and shut down the churches because the
churches are preaching intolerance and
hate that's the that's the end result of
all this B here's the thing here's the
thing I'm a religious Jew I believe in
the Old Testament right I believe in the
Pentateuch I believe in the homage as we
call it or the Torah okay I believe in
the five books of Moses that means that
I personally believe that homosexual
activity is a sin here's the beautiful
thing about America you don't have to
care you don't have to care what I think
you don't have to care whether I think
it's a sin what do you care I think
eating shellfish is a sin for Jews I
think lots of things are sins the Bible
is filled with sins the Bible is filled
with sins and I take those sit-ins
seriously because I'm a religious Jew
you don't have to care you don't believe
in the Bible fine good I don't care
that's fine you can think I'm an idiot
I can think you're a sinner and we can
all live happily together but the minute
that you start saying that my beliefs
based on a godly book in my view that
that makes me incapable of having a show
about fixing up houses now you're a
fascist now you're being a fascist and
the left is being phished istic this is
being fistic I mean this is religious
thought crime they're not but well they
haven't even asked the gains whether
they even agree with the pastor and
you'll notice the hypocrisy here right
Barack Obama went to a church for 20
years 20 years where the pastor didn't
just preach about homosexual activity
the pastor said America should be damned
9/11 was the chickens coming home to
roost and that America created AIDS to
kill black people in Africa right Obama
went to that church for
20 years and then wrote his book The
Audacity of Hope based on a lecture by
that pastor and the media whoa whoa whoa
how dare you attribute Jeremiah Wright's
views to our beautiful wonderful
President Barack Obama how could you do
such a thing
religion is okay for the left so long as
you ascribe to their belief system a
religion is very bad if you don't
describe to their belief system by the
way you'll never see anything similar
like this if there's a Muslim person in
public life like Kareem abdul-jabbar and
he's a religious Muslim you'll never see
the mask remap Kareem what do you think
about homosexual activities at a sin or
not hey they'll never ask a Muslim about
this right the only tool with Christians
because they must root out Christianity
because Christianity makes them feel bad
about themselves and this is what it
really comes down to you don't I don't
have a duty to make you feel good about
yourself I don't have a duty to make you
feel like a non sinner if I think that
you're committing a sin I don't that's
not my duty but you think the government
has a duty to make me stop making you
feel like a sinner that's what people on
the Left believe they believe that the
government or the or the market somebody
has a duty to make me stop making you
feel bad right the only reason you're
feeling bad right now is presumably
because you take my opinion seriously
well if you don't take my opinion
seriously don't take it seriously who
cares again people on the Left say
terrible things about me all the time
people on the alt-right say terrible
things about me all the time I don't
care that's their prerogative welcome to
America but the left has to drum out of
existence all possible dissent and
that's really disgusting and that's
really fascistic it's really gross so
shame on BuzzFeed shame on Cosmo honest
honest to goodness people I mean there
are a lot of people who believe in the
Bible and you want to know why Donald
Trump won really the reasons I don't
Trump one is because the more you bully
people who believe in the Bible into
saying they're bad people who shouldn't
be allowed to raise their kids as they
see fit they shouldn't be allowed to
have TV shows they shouldn't be allowed
to have restaurants they shouldn't be
allowed to operate their businesses they
shouldn't be allowed to raise their
children the more people are gonna tell
y'all to go screw yourselves and I'm not
even set by the way my position on
same-sex marriage governmentally is the
government shouldn't even be involved in
the issue but this pisses me off it does
because you're saying that you get to
rule me you get to take away my career
because of something I think that
doesn't even manifest in behavior it
doesn't even manifest in me mistreating
people and that's absurd that's
thoughtcrime